hi everyone so uh today i'm gonna go
over ai fairness
um so talking about removing unfair bias
in
machine learning and um
just a quick rundown of the agenda we
have only about 25 minutes
so i'm going to go through this pretty
quickly
but i just have a few slides to go
through to give you kind of an
intro to fairness and bias on just a few
different things that we look at
in the ai workflow we're going to look
at some of the metrics and algorithms
and
some of the guidance and then i'm going
to do a short interactive demo
to kind of crystallize some of these
concepts that i'll go through
and then i'll do a healthcare use case
in python
so um you know the main thing i'm going
to go through today
is ai fairness 360. and
what this is is a comprehensive toolkit
for detecting
understanding and mitigating unwanted
algorithmic bias
so um you know there are several metrics
77 metrics 10 bias mitigation algorithms
and several metrics explainers so um
essentially it's an extensible tool kit
for detecting
and removing bias or an attempt to
remove bias
so just really quickly i'm going to go
into you know how
how you measure bias where it comes from
and so you know a lot of people have
seen this imagery but
you know a lot of people think bias
comes
from your algorithm but the underlying
data
is most often the source of the bias not
the algorithm
itself so this can occur due to over
undersampling uh
label bias or user generated bias
models are trained on data from our past
human decisions you know over many
decades often so
this can be reflected as society
societal or historical inequities
so um you know when we look at a
selection bias where one population is
overrepresented
uh or in a training data set you know
mit
recently identified this problem with
the top ratio facial recognition
software
um you know where they've been
predominantly trained on white male data
sets so the results were 99
accurate for lighter skin male and 65
accurate for darker skinned females in
facial recognition so you can imagine
you know if
law enforcement is using wide scale
facial recognition what the implications
would be
if you're a darker skinned female
so a lot of data scientists at events um
ask me why can't i just
drop protected attributes like race
gender age religion
and you can't really drop these
attributes um
because there are too many features that
are very closely correlated
so for example if you're looking at zip
codes
it's very easy to deconstruct an
individual's race or income
uh and this map just kind of shows uh
you know when this was actually legal
banks were doing this specifically to
offer
different amounts to credit to different
racial
uh minorities
so i don't want to read all of this but
just um so you know there are different
types of fairness terms
um that you don't typically see in a
machine learning workflow so
what we'll see in the demo is things
like a protected attribute
and this is something you have to define
um that partitions a population into
groups
whose outcomes should have parity or
equality like race gender
uh religion or age um there's particu
privilege protected attributes so this
um you know could be
uh a particular group that histori has
been historically at a
an advantage um and there's two things
that are you know change things
very differently mathematically which is
group fairness and individual fairness
uh and we're going to spend a lot of
time looking at different fairness
metrics
for some reason my slides are whoops
okay
sides are stuck there
um so just to give you
you know there are 77 different metrics
just to give you kind of a background
on a few of these so we'll look at
things like disparate impact and equal
opportunity difference these are the
ways that you measure bias so something
like statistical parity difference
um this is the difference in favorable
outcomes rate
uh received by that of the unprivileged
group to that of the privileged group so
if for instance six out of ten
african-americans had a favorable
outcome rate and 7 out of 10 whites had
a favorable rate
that difference would be 10 which would
give you
your measurement of bias similarly this
would be dividing those two rates
and that would give you disparate impact
um and so if you're
subtracting these differences in bias
you're going to want to get this as
close to 0 as possible
and for a disparate impact you're going
to want to get this as close to one as
possible and that would
indicate fairness uh when you're
measuring
for bias
and just so you are aware bias can occur
at any stage
in the machine learning pipeline and
fairness metrics and de-biasing
algorithms can be performed at various
stages
so it's recommended to check for bias
as early as possible in your pipeline as
you can by using as many metrics as
possible
that are relevant to your application
and it is good to
integrate bias detection in your
automated pipeline to ensure that you're
continually correcting for bias
so you see that in the use case where
after two years
there was a bias drift if you will
and so um you know really the type of
de-biasing algorithms you use will
depend on where you can intervene in the
pipeline
um you know the best place to do this is
with your data set
so if you can modify the training data
you should use the pre-processing
algorithms
if you can modify the learning algorithm
then you would use in processing
and if you can only treat your learned
model as a black box
and can't modify the training data or
learning algorithm then only
post-processing can be used
and these are just an example of the
algorithms
across the pipeline
and you know just so you're aware this
toolkit
is comprised of the top bias metrics
and de-biasing algorithms in the
industry
they're not uh really just an ibm thing
really this was about
bringing a lot of the open source
toolkits
and research at universities
out into the hands of data scientists in
an easy
scalable way so again you know
pre-processing
is the optimal time to mitigate your
bias you're gonna see this
um in in the use case so a few things
i'll use
are the um disparate impact remover
uh and re-weighing so re-weighing
basically changes the weights
applied to training samples um it
doesn't change your features or labels
and so this is ideal if you can't change
the values so we'll see
some of that uh later in the
presentation
so um you know one of the important
things to to note is
that this isn't a magic bullet it
doesn't solve all bias so there's a
trade-off to this right
um there is a trade-off between bias and
accuracy so
as you do mitigate bias you will see a
loss of prediction accuracy so
you know you really have to think about
as an organization as a data scientist
is your model really doing good or bad
things to people if it's
sending people to jail maybe it's better
to have more false positives and false
negatives
um but if your models handing out loans
maybe it's better to have more
false negatives and false positives so
you really need to
determine your threshold for accuracy
versus fairness
uh based upon your legal and ethical uh
and trust guidelines um and so
you know you obviously have to do what's
legal first and foremost due to
penalties
um but you have to think about what does
what does your company ethically stand
for
and then you know we all want to go
after profits as most businesses do but
you know what is the cost to losing
trust in uh from your customer base
and this is just the final slide before
i jump into
uh the toolkit you know the preventing
bias we're just starting to scratch the
surface here
you know for all tech companies so um
you know we haven't
really solved this problem it's very
difficult but you know the guidance is
to work with your stakeholders early to
define
you know what is fairness for your use
case
um and what are the protected attributes
and thresholds that you're willing to
to live with and again applying the
earliest
bias mitigation in your pipeline as
possible
and checking for bias um as often as
possible using as many
metrics that are applicable so you know
many people hear about the compass
algorithm
and um you know deciding whether
prisoners should go on parole or not um
and it you know it had a significant
amount of bias for african americans but
um they did actually try to measure and
reduce or remove bias from that
algorithm
uh but they did not use as many metrics
as they needed to
to discover the bias um
so with that i'm just gonna
show you you know
aifairness360.bluemix.net this
is uh the website to the toolkit um
you can you know do things such as do
the demos look at some of the notebooks
and look at some of the algorithms and
metrics just just
to learn more um
up here you'll have the api docs which
are very informative
um so for each sort of metric you can
look at what are the parameters
the raises um the methods methods
and the the returns so this is very
um important to understanding you know
what you're applying
and you know what is the equation behind
that metric or algorithm
so what we're going to do here is um
just a quick demo so you can kind of
visualize
what we were talking about earlier so
what i'm going to do is look at the
compass
algorithm and this predicts a criminal's
defendant's likelihood of reoffending
so um like we spoke about earlier
there's protected attributes
so in this case it's going to be sex and
the privilege class is female
and the unprivileged class is male um
you know men are
considered unprivileged in the criminal
justice system and may be accused more
frequently than women
and then for race the privileged classes
caucasian and unprivileged class
is not caucasian
so um if we run this data set
and we measure for bias
we'll see here that um for the attribute
protected attribute of sex
um you know the prediction actually is
66 percent
but four out of five of these metrics
show bias for sex so you can see in red
here
um these metrics should be measuring
much closer to zero and this should be
close to one
and for race we also see bias in four
out of five of these metrics
um for statistical parity difference
equal opportunity difference average
odds difference
and distributed disparate impact
so what i'm going to do here is
use the re-weighing algorithm and this
is pre-processing so this
weights the examples in each group
or label differently to ensure fairness
before classification
but as you can see down here there's uh
two different algorithms you could use
there
you could use an in processing algorithm
or
post-processing but i'm going to you
know run this
model again after re-weighing that data
set
and what you'll see here is for the
protected attribute of sex
the prediction accuracy was unchanged
you know still at 66 percent
uh but what we can see here in the
before and after
is that the bias measurement has
significantly reduced
so much closer to zero here and closer
to one for disparate impact
and this is the same for race as well
so we'll see um that prediction accuracy
hasn't changed much
but we have uh reduced bias
significantly across the board
so um with that i'm going to just go
into a quick
medical expenditure tutorial and so what
we're going to do is look at
how bias occurs in healthcare data and
how we can mitigate it
with ai fairness 360. so just to give a
an overview of this use case health
insurance companies uh
like to treat patients differently when
providing managed care
for things like say diabetes or heart
disease
so they'll use algorithms to look at
patients and their data to prioritize
cases for care management
however in the u.s whites utilize
managed care more often than
african-americans
on average and this propagates into the
data set
um and into your model as bias so
um you know first and foremost so why do
african americans spend less
on healthcare than whites so there's a
lot of research and data around this
um one of the reasons is that african
americans
may have jobs that don't allow them to
take off
for medical appointments and this is
even if they have health insurance
the second is that doctors often treat
african-americans with implicit bias and
may not believe their patient is as sick
as they're
reporting to be so less health care
treatment is prescribed
and i don't know if you follow the news
and see that saw that michael bloomberg
donated about 100 million dollars to
black medical colleges to increase the
number of black doctors
so um you know the third reason is
really african americans
may not trust uh their white doctors so
they may not trust the health care
treatment that's prescribed so
because of those three reasons you know
you have doctors decisions
and patience decisions and those two
things have created
bias in your data set so basically if
you
if your model shows that a particular
race spends more money
or less uh and uses less healthcare
services your model will be biased and
predicting how sick a patient is and
whether they need managed care
so it's important to ensure that you
have fairness in your model
uh and in your data set
so if we go down here
this is basically a demonstrating
bias and healthcare classification model
we build a classifier using
logistic regression um this notebook
does random forest models
but i'm going to just um do the logistic
regression due to time
and we're going to detect bias using
five different metrics
and then we're going to do two different
approaches to bias mitigation so
pre-processing
as well as in processing and then for
the data set
we're using the medical expenditure
uh panel survey and essentially this
is uh the most complete source of data
on the cost and use of health care
and health insurance coverage in the u.s
so it's a large set
a scale of surveys of families
medical providers and employers across
the us
so um the features that we're going to
the protected attribute that we're going
to focus on is the
uh race so the privilege class will be
defined as
white and the unprivileged class will be
defined as non-white
and there are a lot of other features in
the model
including demographics you know such as
age
gender active duty status and
also physical mental health assessments
and things like diagnosis for cancer
diabetes
and physical limitations such as
cognitive hearing or vision
so the model classification task is
really going to be to predict
whether a person has or will have high
utilization
um of of health visits so that would be
greater than
or equal to 10 visits
per year to the doctor and that's about
the average in the in the u.s
per year okay
so um the steps that we're going to take
here
are we're going to look at three panels
of data
so uh we're going to look at panel 19
panel 20 and panel 21
of people who are continuously
monitoring sampled for a year from 2014
to 2016.
um so we'll use panel 19 for training
models panel 20 for deploying
and panel 21 for retraining to correct
for the bias drift
so um basically here what we're going to
do is
import the standard python ai fairness
360
packages uh import the lime explainers
as well as scikit-learn
[Music]
and then to simulate the scenario we're
going to split the data into train
validation into chess set and again
we're defining the
privileged and unprivileged class as
whites and non-whites
and just a quick summary of the data set
there are 7915 patients
in the training set 4749 and validation
3166 in the test set and there are 138
features
and again here's the uh protected
attribute of race
but there are many many features as you
can see here we won't
go through all of those
and so first what we're going to do is
measure
bias on the original data set by using
the disparate impact metric
and you'll see that right here the
disparate impact is measured at 0.48 and
this number should actually be much
closer to 1 so this indicates that there
is bias in the original data set
so now we're going to look at the
logistic reaction model on the original
data
and uh once we do that we'll see down
here that
the prediction accuracy is good when we
use one minus discrete impact or average
odds difference
so prediction accuracy is 76 percent
uh but you find that um you know a lot
of these metrics
the level of bias is too high and should
be much closer to zero
this is just biased for the training
data so um when we look back down at the
testing data we see that
you know it's the same kind of scenario
of uh high level bias
so the point we're just trying to make
is that the original data set is unfair
and hence the model we're using
will be unfair due to that data
so we're going to skip through the
random forest models
because that's essentially the same
process that we went through
before so now i'm going to
apply re-weighing on the original data
and it associates what this is going to
do is associate a weight
to each data point so that the final
data set
you obtain is more fair so once you do
this
um you'll see you know again we're
measuring disparate impact
and after applying that algorithm
disparate impact is one
and so this is really good this
indicates that the data set is much more
fair
so again you know just going back and
training the
uh retraining the data set
with that was has been reweighed uh and
we'll see that the prediction accuracy
is gone from 0.77 to 0.75
and the level of bias is improved by an
order of magnitude
and that's for the train and test set as
well
so again we're going to skip through the
random forest part
and what we're going to do is look at an
in-processing technique
called the prejudice remover this
algorithm
changes the model by directly applying
constraints so again the in processing
algorithms directly change the model
itself versus preprocessing what we saw
before
changes the data
so um you know when we run through this
model
using the prejudice remover we see that
essentially prediction accuracy has gone
down
to from 0.77 to 68 percent
um however the bias has reduced
um significantly so you know you really
have to be careful with your approach
uh the type of approach that you use
because this did
impact the uh prediction accuracy
significantly
and right here is just kind of a summary
of results right we used um
two different types of approaches on the
original data we used re-weighing
as well as the prejudice remover so you
can see when you go back to this
notebook later
how it impacted the bias measurement and
prediction accuracy
so you know if we want to go back and
check for
um you know when we're satisfied with
our bias mitigation we can go back
and check after a year by deploying this
model on panel 20 data so
2014 data and model used in 20 000 uh
2015
um and that when we do that
we can see that um the
bias prediction accuracy went from 77 to
73
so that's pretty good um and the bias
measurements here show that
bias is still pretty good so it hasn't
drifted much over one year
and you know if i i'm going to go back
to the lime explainers
if we now look at we're going to test
the model that was trained
using panel 19 data on panel 21 data so
this is two years later
if we just take this model and redeploy
it
we'll see here that our prediction
accuracy is good
um but again the bias
increased over two years so not in the
first year uh
but it it increased during the second
year
so again we need to refresh this model
with data from 2015
and again redeploy that back out into
2016 models so we're able to correct for
that bias drift
so that's just an important thing to to
keep in mind um
that you can't just do this on the front
end you need to continuously check for
bias
um over time
and if i go back up into the lime
explainers
and i'm getting just to the end of time
here
um you know it's it's important this is
uh two different instances
um but we're going to visualize the
explanation using the lyme model
and just for two particular patients um
essentially we can see that these
features indicate what's important
and their weights that contribute to
whether a patient
uh requires more managed care or not um
so essentially the right hand side shows
the actual values of the feature in the
partic
uh particular instance um
and the associated weights so these are
things like chronic bronchitis
smoking pregnancy emphysema etc
so it's important to look at um
you know what is contributing and you
know oftentimes nurses may go back and
do this what is contributing to
a model predicting whether a patient is
high risk
um and requires more managed care
so um just a quick summary of everything
we've done here i know this is uh
very quick but essentially
the original model from 2014 was very
unfair when we deployed
it in 2016 so we retrain that model
using the latest data and this improved
the fairness and accuracy
so again really important to
continuously check for your model
and drift over time um but also
to try different approaches you know
it's best to mitigate bias on your data
set but you may not always be able to do
that
but it is important to to use as many
metrics as possible to
to ensure you're checking for bias in as
many different ways as you can
so with that um
i think the last thing i might leave you
with in chat
um is a few resources so i'll put this
in chat
and this is where you would get the
demos tutorials and notebooks
uh you can join the af 360 slack we have
a ton of researchers and developers who
answer all sorts of questions and they
run
very broadly across the gamut and i also
worked on a book with
our researchers and this is a free book
um
by or riley who published it but we
wrote it
this will just give you more detail
around the topic
and it's pretty short so it's easy to
read
and um i'll put those
in um much this was great
and uh very short sorry just rushing
through
everything yeah i know it was great very
great and very very informative so thank
you very much i'm sure
all the attendees really enjoyed it here
um so thank you again trisha
thank you thanks everybody for for
coming this is that's all that we've got
now so
um i hope you enjoyed both of our
speakers i hope you enjoyed
interacting with some of the other
attendees where we'll be sure to get
another event
like this going and if you have any
feedback on kind of the process or what
we're doing or if you have any ideas
for talks that you would want to give or
anybody else go ahead to the respective
meetup pages we still have our own
miami new york and philly pages where
you can just drop a comment there or
contact one of the organizers but
thank you all again for coming and have
a good night
bye